okk two boys like a Ravel we're gonna
play this mission called the Belgian
problem appears we've waited long enough
now we go for the wrench don't be easy
the whole towers gotta cut yeah yes what
have we done things the easy way true so
what's the plan kill everyone we see on
day it's time just tell me where to be
your meeting in the penthouse I am gonna
kill that son of a [ __ ] yeah he won't
get away this time you bet your ass he
won't Annie atenea there's any on that I
[ __ ] to get down okay okay [ __ ] it
get and dissing it cuz nobody oh shut
shut
okay yeah pocket pocket
you
no tents come on today's that's a little
big for you give me the goddamn gun
Pierce okay all right let's give that
[ __ ] what's coming so steady
[ __ ] i love today's
huh it is I can't even concentrate
teddies are great
Shaun be you gonna be okay coming along
don't worry about me I need this l'wren
has to pay for what he did and I want to
be there when he gets what he deserves I
worry girl that guy and I stopping will
around we're taking out his whole
[ __ ] syntech I think we'll need to do
a little more than kill one guy to do
that you know that bomb we stole well
there you go oh yeah Brett we saw that
huge [ __ ] thing
how'd you think pineapple equally he'll
be on the top floor I think it's in that
criminal mastermind rulebook for
something you think he's gonna be that
cliche yeah we're killing everyone in
there I got got got got this is cut this
is god what the cause appears right move
the giant bomb near a firefight oh it's
all taken care of soon as we make sure
the loading dock is clear they'll drive
it in
thank God God oh oh hell no times you go
check that gun how long is it gonna take
us to get there oh just rhyming like you
don't get this driving every day yeah
guy like I need to say what psycho
babble is a [ __ ] expert I know when I
first took my driving test I was like
where's the nitrous [ __ ] and he was
like I ain't [ __ ] around here oh [ __ ]
they have snipers in here okay keep the
car parks out here okay looks like we
get it so this is easier just to do
that's god I came rolling betcha you
brought on this patch
[ __ ] I got stuck
okay okay
not [ __ ] well Saints are here
chef Dave chipped a nail kepta now oh
shet that big guy really doesn't want us
to get inside holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
that
I gotta take this [ __ ] out myself yeah
ate a fatwa eat your protein J and suck
my tendons to the cops approached get in
breast milk you know what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying protein per
prisoner although all of you guys go
here's our delivery now any news i
deliver it now ok dad god i can find it
up sorry bomb said in two clocks tick
why didn't we wait to do that until
after we kill the run that's a really
good question we should move it [ __ ]
there's a lot of time now [ __ ] it what
did you do it wasn't me did you stop
expect to find up to my office where I
could hold heat
chef
still think I'm just a pretty face hey
Zeller ends there's that
okay was impressive
keep seen clones we probably should have
seen that coming what yeah you're right
this [ __ ] crazy this guy's slow me
down okay what do we call these guys who
cares they're blowing up with the rest
of this plate how about bricks it's guy
slowly down chase that so they see that
really all right what would you call him
John you ain't getting out his work
sorry
that was fun I know this wasn't be easy
geez
wow there's like no actresses
there we go we did have we did shed now
look at what the pho since [ __ ] didn't
[ __ ] show up ok ok i'm running or on
it
this is
I did breeches that's high 20 s tennis
yeah buddy bad [ __ ] the [ __ ] so
blowing if she was under all this what
is that I list Jesus disgusting Philip
likes his thing's got the mid and for
his brutes I am the master pattern you
see why are you still strung up that
they already cloned your ass the copies
are flawed they have my brawn but not my
brain I can help you the last time a big
naked dude said he could help me it did
not in America what could he do anyway
just wasn't should've probably keeping
him alive trust me I'm still strong
enough to kill Philippe see like blind
aha that's kind of I guess here not like
my second wife huge bouncy slows me no
time
I can't
and like I said last time a big naked
dude all right think it is a nice
elevator will take us to the offices and
she's so blurred yeah chase asleep at us
follow me to Phillips office ss-sorry
drinking you know I'd like a curvature
important to stay hydrated ok nothing to
be ashamed of unless you have
insecurities I'm good got a name Lenny
my name is Olli kittle off so what did
you do before you were a glorified pin
cushion I think it's best for our
friendship I never elaborate what is
this just know that the enemy of your
enemy is your friend as long as you
oppose the syndicate you have nothing to
fear then we'll be all good Daisy let's
have you in the Saints
that guy's huge it Lawrence office is
this
would be at shop can fix elevator to the
basement there's no way to catch him
[ __ ] that what get this thing loose
leave it to me I've got this one tons of
a stick this is our only shot oh I gotta
get finial or nothing oh my god what the
[ __ ] is he like trying
ok
Derek kills to get off what what though
really could have used an eighties
action hero joke
time to blow this place to help I hear
this place more than anyone but it would
be folly to destroy Phillips research
without seeing what we can hub is fun we
came here to send a message didn't we
why not keep the building for yourself
your choice here boss Huck we're gonna
have to do something about the pink
you'd prefer a more manly shed like
purple yeah okay thanks for watching
dips out for Harambee